workers battling the elements on their
way to the office it's almost as if the
pandemic never happened
but the lockdowns have left some scars I
was struggling at work I felt depressed
I felt alone
James suffered a mental health crisis in
early 2020. his employer paid for some
counseling but it was not enough
they came back to me to say it's you've
spent your budget and
we can't
support you any longer in terms of
giving you mental health support
so
that was probably my lowest point he's
not alone
people have been leaving the world of
work in record numbers mainly because of
long-term sickness
levels of economic inactivity among the
long-term sick have risen by more than
half a million since the pandemic
the majority of this increase is related
to mental health problems
and a growing number of people in work
are also reporting long-term health
problems
the key driver mental health conditions
after hitting rock bottom James received
help from a specialist company one of a
growing number that are trying to solve
this problem
this is the portal you don't have to go
through anyone in the company to access
it
Joel set up an online platform to help
employers offer more tailored support to
their workers you've got lots of your
Workforce Now suffering depression
suffering more anxiety if you don't
support your Workforce you're going to
have poor poor employee outcomes which
are going to create poor business
outcomes this is an issue that affects
everybody because with a smaller
Workforce comes smaller economic growth
and if businesses are struggling to
recruit they may be forced into paying
higher wages
good for some but a concern for the bank
of England which fears that it could
fuel price pressures at a time when
inflation is already running rampant
there's a recession on the horizon and a
cost of living crisis in full flow all
of this will take a toll on a country
already in the grip of a mental health
crisis
Sky News